we're happy to have anupam gupta from
cmu who is going to test about robust
algorithms for online decision making
okay uh thanks ed thanks everybody for
uh
hanging around so i'm going to talk
about some work that i've been doing
with a bunch of people i'm not going to
list them but
it's going to be about robust algorithms
sort of bridging between
the worst case and the stochastic case
which
most of you have known and many of you
work on this area so i just want to
advertise a
little bit of work and some interesting
questions out there
so you know the the way i've been
thinking about this is that
you know these are the two ends of the
spectrum there's a worst case algorithm
design
and there's this sort of stochastic
algorithm design
worst case is great uh you know in the
stochastic case the model may be
given it may be learned you know it
depends on us
uh the worst case is great it's very
robust and that's
that's really one of the big selling
points right and but unfortunately what
happens is it is the worst case so often
on your instances it might be too
pessimistic
as opposed to uh you know in the on the
stochastic case you are assuming a
certain model
that your data is coming from or you're
assuming certain data behavior
and so you can get very strong results
so it's really a trade-off between
robustness and optimality and the more
you assume the stronger the results you
could get
but of course it could be too stylized
too optimistic
and really the the point i want to make
is that very often
the algorithms that we're designing we
might be over
fitting to the model so can we actually
get models
which are robust to adversarial noise in
this sense
that uh there is some amount of
adversarial
corruption that happens you can think of
this as a semi-random model if you will
so uh today i'll just study this in the
context of
you know online decision making and uh
but you can imagine this in
a slightly more broader context as well
so today's menu you know it's a little
ambitious but we'll see how far we can
get
it's a i mostly focus on secretary
problems which most of you know about i
guess but i'll introduce it
and i'll talk about adversarial and
stochastic models both
and then we'll uh we'll you know give
some algorithmic ideas and then maybe
we'll talk a little about bandwidth
problems as well but
i i won't hold my breath it's uh time
goes faster when you're having fun
right so okay so the secretary problem
so many of you know about basically you
have n
unknown values which have been chosen by
the adversary you don't know these
values
but you want to pick the highest one of
these so you want to let's say maximize
the probability of picking the highest
one or
maximize the expected values that you're
picking
so you can pick maybe one item k items
these are both
possible uh options and then uh
the the the way they come you know if
you uh
the way it's modeled this is an
equivalent way to the way that it's
modeled
each of these items comes at a random
time and these times i've chosen iid
between zero and one let's say and once
you see an item you have to decide
immediately whether you're going to pick
it or not
and if you pick it that's the one item
you want to pick so if you're picking k
items you can pick items but once you
pick an item you can't discard it after
that
so you might say well you know the first
item is unlikely to be the max so you
don't pick it
etc you can wait and then you can see
how
how it goes and then you know at some
point you might decide to pick the item
so um and of course you can't go back
etc etc
so by the way feel free to ask questions
if there's anything unclear
and feel free to sort of un uh mute your
uh videos as well at least
i i can i can figure out whether people
want more feedback
anyways good so the secretary problem as
you guys know
uh is is well solved it's been studied
since
uh you know it's even got articles
saying who solved the secretary problem
uh so the the classic one is called
dinkins algorithm
and it's for a single item and it says
you know
wait until half time so basically ignore
all the items until the half time
and then once you get to half time okay
the the animation is not really working
for me so let me just show you the
animation
you you wait until half time and then
you choose
the item that was the max in the first
half and use that as a threshold and any
item in the second half which is bigger
than the
this this threshold you pick
so uh so this is a is a quarter
this has a quarter chance of picking the
max item
because if the maximum the highest item
indeed comes in the second half which
has a probability of a half and the
second highest comes in the first half
which has a probability of another half
then you'll definitely pick v1
so that's a quarter probability of
success and by optimizing this threshold
to not be at one half
but at one over e you can show that you
have a one over e
probability of picking the highest and
this is the best possible etc you know
this problem
we understand completely in some sense
and you can extend this to picking k
items and the advantage of k items is
you can afford to screw up once in a
while
so actually you can start using just uh
you know huffing bounds
and what you can do is you can actually
start making an estimate fairly early
so at time epsilon so if this is time
epsilon
now the time epsilon you expect to see
epsilon k of the items
of the top k items you've seen epsilon n
of all the items
you you've seen epsilon k of the top k
items so if you set your threshold
to be like the epsilon kx largest item
that's a pretty good threshold to go for
and indeed you can show that if you pick
items greater than this threshold and
i'm cheating a little bit
because you know you need to account for
variance but you can control the
variance so
as long as k the number of items you're
picking
is you know something which depends on
one over epsilon it's like one over
epsilon squared
which is coming for the usual churn of
type reasons
you you do pretty well okay
so if you want to pick many items you
can get one over there or one minus
epsilon approximation if you want to
pick a single item like a one over
reapproximation
so this remember we assumed that all the
items were coming at random times
or in random order really and
this is you know one end of my spectrum
the other end of my spectrum is of
course the adversarial setting
and the adversarial setting things are
hopeless because basically i'll tell you
i'm going to give you a sequence like
this of increasing valued items
and then at some point you're going to
fall off a cliff and from then on you'll
just get zero valued items
you just don't know where the last item
is and if you
if you were you know if the gap between
items is fairly large
then you know you don't want to pick the
second highest item you really do want
to pick the highest item
but you don't know where the highest is
so random guessing is the best you can
do and you can make this format it's
it's not a
big deal so um
so given that um
sorry powerpoint seems to be misbehaving
so
i'm sorry guys just give me a second
not completely sure uh can you guys
see my screen
perfect yeah good good
so you know random guessing was the best
you could do so
this is not a good idea so in this case
what's happening is
that the worst case has a terrible
approximation
and the the best case has a very good
approximation but of course it
really relies on this random ordering so
for instance what happens is
what if some items come in random order
and the rest in adversarial order if i
wanted to
you know kind of mess up this algorithm
i could introduce a small number of high
valued items
right at the beginning when i'm setting
my thresholds
and then the algorithms just completely
fail right
so in some sense if i wanted to model
the world in some sense and i'm assuming
that the world is mostly random
that doesn't quite work it has to be
completely random for things to work
so that's the uh that's the setting in
which we come in and we ask the question
what happens in a sort of byzantine
world so let me just make the
model formal the model says well you
have
two kinds of items red and green of
course you don't see the colors
all the values are adversarial as before
the red items come at adversarial time
so the adversary picks the times where
they give the right items
the green items come in random at random
times
just as before so if all the items were
green this is the old problem
if all the items are red this is the
adversarial hopeless problem
of course items elements don't reveal
their colors
and the the existing algorithms don't do
well
so the question is can you actually give
algorithms that do do well
so that's going to be the uh the the
hope now of course what's the benchmark
and you you know you think for 30
seconds and you realize that you can't
really hope to compare against the
global optimum the you know if all the
green values were
had value zero and all the reds had all
the value you can't
hope you know this is adversarial you
can't hope to compete with that
so you can't hope to get the max overall
you know if the greens are useless the
reds are really encoding a hard instance
so uh instead what you you know a
reasonable thing is that you'll you just
compare yourself to the max valued set
you know maybe the single item maybe k
items amongst just the green elements
the good guys green for good
okay okay good
so that's the main setting and for today
i'm going to assume
that i know whatever benchmark i have
you know this is the best the value of
the best set
it's not really the max ed it's the
value of this max set
and for today i'm going to assume that i
know some polynomial in
n approximation to this value
i can get rid of it with an additive
loss it's like a regret type
loss that i might need to suffer but for
today just imagine that i have some
polynomial approximation to be star
okay so are there any questions about uh
anything so far before i is the model
clear is the problem clear
clear to me perfect thank you
so uh by the way seb uh i don't have a
clock in front of me so tell me when to
stop and i'll stop
sounds good okay so let me tell you the
results and then
you know okay so if you want to pick k
items
i can get like a one minus epsilon
approximation as before
but now earlier i had said look as long
as you have many items so you can get a
1 minus epsilon
and earlier i just had a k being like
omega of 1 over epsilon squared earlier
now i have these dubious extra losses
i believe this is essential but i don't
have a proof yet
so i can't get within one minus epsilon
of the past
if i'm picking k items and if you've
been you know if you follow this line of
work there's a natural extension
to d-dimensional packing problems
and there again you can get results
somewhat like this
though the performance is worse but
there's some dependence on b
as well but for today
maybe just think of this as packing k
items you can get arbitrary close to
optimum even with
noise
and then there's this sort of cute
little result that maybe i'll mention
right at the beginning
i can show you how to pick a single item
whose value is like a
one over log star fraction
of the optimum
and it's like a uh i
i don't have a lower bond and i believe
it should be a constant but i don't
uh know how to do that either so if
you're if you're bored you should think
about this uh
this question you just want to pick a
single item
in this adversary in this mildly
adversarial setting
okay so that's what i'm going to do yeah
quick question
um just a question about the model does
the algorithm know how many red items
there
are or just nothing at all about that so
the
the algorithm does not know how many red
items there are
and all it knows at least for today i'm
making the assumption that it has some
polynomial approximation to this v star
so it has some
ballpark guess of where v star
is but it's like some polynomial range
okay thanks okay good
okay so that's what i'm going to do i'm
going to tell you about these two
results
and maybe i'll tell you about theorem 2
first because it's kind of cute and
yeah okay
so single item you want to pick a single
item and get good value
and we assume that we have this
polynomial approximation rupees down
okay so one of the standard tricks that
in in this
thing that you can do is you can make
these like log n value levels
these are all the elements of between
values you know one and two
these are two and four four and eight
eight and sixteen and so on so forth
and so since these are logarithmically
uh
many here's the trivial log
approximation
you are looking for the best green item
somewhere
and maybe i can use green
the best green item lies somewhere
so if all you did was just guest a
random one of these log many
value levels and pick any item in that
you'd get a one over log n approximation
okay pick a random level pick an item in
that you're done
it's a one in login approximation it's
it's like a boring thing this but you
know just keep this in mind
okay here's another obvious thing
if all the spurious items all the reds
the the noise are smaller than the max
green then this
dinkins algorithm still works because
the greens are coming in random order
so as long as the reds are smaller than
this max green
they won't mess you up
okay so these are the two things to keep
in mind
okay and now i can give you the
algorithm
which is like you know a log
approximation
i'll give you a log log approximation
okay so here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to take all of time
time between 0 and 1 and i'm going to
break it into two parts just
two halves so this is just time half
in the middle the
okay now i must have
a red item oh so but just for a scaling
i have imagine that
v star that the max green item that i'm
looking for lies in this
this level out here you just don't know
what time it arrives
it arrives at a uniformly random time
good so now i'm saying well
there must exist at least one red item
in the first half
that is bigger than v star because other
otherwise the first half
if you know the first half is behaving
like a secretary problem
without any red guys or the red guys are
low
so there must exist at least one red
person on the left hand side on the
in the first half between times zero on
one half
okay there must also exist red guys on
the right hand side which are above v
star that's okay okay
now this red guy can be anywhere
now my claim is that if this red guy
remember the values go up exponentially
right
1 2 4 8 and so on so forth
if the red guy lies way above here
and then it has value at least log n
times v
star then picking it just to have a one
in log n chance of picking it
but once i pick it i get log n times v
star i'm i'm all set
i'm very happy
so if this red guy lies above here
right values more than log n times v
star i am
i i win with constant probability
oh sorry not with constant probability
the the expected value i get
is a constant times v star i win with
low probability but
still that's okay so the bad case is
that all the red elements in the first
half
lie small or small
but that in turn means that the highest
red item in the first half
is a log approximation to v star
okay so think about it i started with
the polynomial approximation to v star
and after this first half i have a log
approximation to b star
okay so that's that's great right
because if i have a log approximation to
v star
then in the second round i'll need only
log log
many uh buckets
in which to run this
good and once you once once you see this
then it's very natural for you to say
look actually you know it's it's
extending this
to uh to to you know further setting
you know to to a further improvement is
not very disconnected
you know have log star many stages of
refinement
in each stage either you get high value
or you refine your estimate of v star
and then you keep on doing this and
finally choose one of these
log star many bucket logs down many
intervals in which to play the
game
so this idea you know this idea of
iterative improvement
is uh is kind of a sort of clean nice
idea and
we used it for a couple of algorithms in
this setting
so uh so just one one thing one trick to
keep in mind
in this in this neck afterwards
the natural uh open question that i
don't know the answer to
is how do i get a constant factor
approximation or could i get a
lower bound which shows that you know
log star is the best we can do
i don't quite know how how to do this
good so maybe what i'll do in the sort
of remaining time that i have
is uh i'll uh i'll tell you about the
algorithm for
the best k items which has a slightly
different flavor to it which i'd call
you know sort of show optimism and
you know this is this is an idea we
often use and uh
in on these problems you know optimism
in the face of uncertainty right
so this is optim you know show optimism
but
verify you understand just
say that again you have 10 more minutes
perfect that's exactly what i need
so um so good so now i'll tell you
about the algorithm for picking let's
say k items and i'll
maybe a little more impressionistic
about the proof
but you know you can fill it in fill in
the details yourself i'm sure
so here's here's the thing pick a items
i want to get large value
and maybe i won't obsess about the
epsilons
i'll just say constant times v star you
can extend all this
i want you to get the some of the main
ideas out here
so um good again i know a polynomial
approximation to this value
and as before i'm going to just make log
n value scales with almost you know all
the values sitting in these log n values
scales
okay and now i'm going to for for
simplicity for
just being able to think about these
things well i'm going to assume
that every value level out here so these
are value levels right
just powers of two either they have a
lot
of green items good items
or they have no good items
there's of course this middle ground
between lots and none at
all but we can handle this later on you
know
it's not important so each value level
is either highly populated with greens
or is empty of greens there might be
reds everywhere who knows
so you know you'd wonder why we do this
it's just because you know
if i put down a uh if i break up time
into intervals
then if i have lots of green items and
if i have only let's say log many
intervals out here
then the number of number of green items
in each group
should behave like the average just turn
off parts
and that's the idea that if things
behave like they're average
then you can you can anticipate for them
even if there's noise out there at least
in this case
okay so so here's the here's the idea
so the idea is break time into c
intervals think of c
as log so you know think of this
as log that's log for sure
and think of c the number of intervals
there's also log
but this log this you know log over
epsilon let's say or something like this
so
so the number of intervals is much more
than number of
uh value levels okay
you want to pick k items overall so in
each group
in each in each interval like this you
should pick about k over c
which k over c should you pick
so the natural thing is to pick k over c
of the highest value items so here's
what we're going to do we're going to
create budgets
for each of these levels value levels
and i'm going to set these
optimistically i'm going to you know
hope for the best
so initially i'm going to say try to
pick k over c items from this
first highest value level of the first
interval now of course there might not
be enough items out there
so imagine that you picked only so many
items
this much got wasted so what i'll do the
next time is
i'll set my budget to be the same
i'll say look i'm going to
optimistically imagine that all these
guys were greens
all these guys were good so i'm going to
hope that past performance is a
predictor of future success
so i'm going to set my budget to be that
much i'm going to pick that many
what happens to this next budget i'll
say well i'll be optimistic i'll move
that budget down here
and now i try again and maybe in the
next round some of this budget gets used
here
some of this maybe some of this budget
gets used here
that the used up budget goes to the next
level the unused budget goes
down below this used up budget stays
where it was this unused budget goes
down below basically
every time i don't pick an item in a
level that i want to pick it
i i i move the budget down i say i
over provision in this level
so more or less you know i can summarize
this thing i can break time into c
intervals
in each interval and in each bucket like
this
i set a budget and i set it to be the
highest possible
given the past so i say look
if i set my budget to be this this
budget should be
the number of items of this you know
the budget here should be the number of
items in this
bucket i saw in the first round number
of items i saw in the second round the
min of those things
because remember the green guys are
coming randomly so the number of green
guys in each
is just behaving like its expectation
it's the right guys who can confuse me
and i set the budgets to be as high as
possible because i want the highest
value
and more or less the the argument goes
the first thing you should do is just
convince yourself if everything is green
then people behave like the average if
there are so many green items
at a level then you see that divided by
c items in each interval
and then you're going to you're going to
get good value i'm not going to go over
the details out here
i'll put up the slides you can have a
look later on
and even if red items are there
basically what happens is
every time you don't pick items
that budget moves downwards
but so the every time the budgets i
i think of this as the budgets are
slipping down
but the budgets can never go below
the optimal occupancy or optimal
occupancy
this is remember the this is the green
optima
because the green optimum is behaving
like it's average
in each and every interval
so you will be picking items you know
because you were being optimistic you
were doing at least as well as opt was
the optimal green was
the only reason your your suffering is
your
you had budget that you did not use
but if you didn't use budget you are
you're starting to make progress towards
becoming like home
so if you do the analysis basically you
say well
your loss is due to the unused budget
and
there's this little calculation you can
do and you know it's it's as simple as
this slide
but you know it's it's late enough in
the talk so i won't
do that maybe i'll just wrap up
if i wanted to get k items i can do it
provided k is large enough
there were some loose ends you know i
made an assumption that every value
level was either rich or empty
you can you can assign a little local
budget to take care of it
there's minor details but the point i
want to make is
what we were doing was optimism in the
face of uncertainty
but being cautious about it check your
work
every so often
and there's some sort of natural open
questions some some
detailed open questions out here but
maybe i'll uh
i'll i'll jump to the last slide and
i'll say
so so one thing i didn't do was i didn't
talk at all about multi-arm bandits
but you know again have a look at the
slides or
actually doris i think is giving a talk
next week
as part of the semester program and
he'll be talking about some extensions
of this multi-unbanded stuff to uh
rl so yeah you can check that out
so basically what we saw were these
stochastic problems so this is bridging
between stochastic
and worst case so stochastic problems
with adversarial corruption
an idea which has been around for quite
some time and i just
presented one set of works on this
and uh both you know so the two
algorithms the other one that i didn't
present also uses this idea of cautious
optimism
but the sort of the the the message i
want to say is that this is
sort of a line of work that i really
like and would be interesting to see
more sort of investigation of this in
particular are these the right models as
well
are these the right questions the right
benchmarks the right algorithms
so anyways many questions to be solved
i'd be very interested in hearing if you
have any thoughts on this
so thank you thanks um
so do we have any question directly for
anytime before we move to the more
general discussion
we have many uh bandit experts on
on the call so maybe you can just say
what is the result that you have on
mandates
like you don't need to define the
problem i mean good so so the
the main idea is if you are this is a
stochastic bandit problem with
there are uh there let's say that c of
the rounds
are allowed to be corrupted and
where the answers are given not
according to the uh
you know the underlying probabilities
but just just arbitrary answers
and then the regret that you get
is now like there's a term which depends
on c
and then there's a term which depends on
uh
you know i can i can even share that
slide out here
so uh
good so i regret kind of behaves like
c uh you know it depends on c and also
on the number of arms i don't know if i
believe that the k
should be there and then this is the
usual
uh ucb type guarantee with slightly
worse performances out here
you see and this is regret with respect
to the underlying
like true stochastic model yes
yes so like if c is equal to t then
there is nothing you can do
it's not like like you cannot you cannot
hope for it's not like
a square with c would be possible
exactly
okay okay okay and then and yeah maybe i
can mention that
you know the ideas are similar to this
active arm elimination
but we are being we're trying to do
active iron elimination but a softer
version of that
okay i think you'd never really
eliminate an arm because just noise
just the corruption can cause you to
eliminate
arms that you really don't want to
eliminate so you kind of
downgrade arms and upgrade arms
depending on i see i see and
okay i'm i would okay is is a
ck at the term optimal i mean do you
need it
so you need a c i don't believe you need
the k but i don't know how to get rid of
it
okay maybe i have more questions but
let's let's move to the broad discussion
period so we can ask any question